à quoi sert une école en 2050 à semer
des graines de connaissances je ne sais
pas comment vous représenter l'ensemble
des connaissances humaines
pour ma part je les vois comme une
immense forêt chacun d'entre nous est
une parcelle de cette forêt et les
plantes les arbres que nous laissons
pousser sur cette parcelle sont les
savoir que nous maîtrisons assez pour
être capable de les enseigner aux autres
il ya des plantes qui poussent
spontanément par contact comme des
recettes de cuisine ou de bricolage
d'autres qui demandent à être semées
parfois dans l'enfance par l'école ou
l'université il ya des arbres
d'astronomie les arbres littérature
médiévale
il y à des arbres dont les fruits sont
indispensables à la survie matérielle de
l'humanité sont des arbres de science et
de technologie
il y en a d'autres dont le bois est si
solide qu'il permet de construire des
maisons extrêmement durable ce sont des
arbres de sagesse et enfin des arbres
dans la seule utilité est de produire
des fleurs magnifiques au parfum
délicieux ce sont des arbres d'art et de
poésie
les graines qui donne la vie à ces
arbres ce sont des livres
certains livres et plus nous lisons et
nous relisons ses livres plus les arbres
en nous grandissent et puis nous sommes
nombreux à lire ses livres plus la forêt
s'étend et nous protège
aujourd'hui en 2050
cette forêt menacée elle a failli être
entièrement détruite des pans entiers de
connaissances sont perdus des
technologies que nous pensions maîtrisée
sont oubliés nous sommes incapables de
produire certains antibiotiques
nous sommes incapables d'envoyer un
satellite dans l'espace la forêt de
connaissances doit absolument être
replantés mais comment en 2050
les livres sont devenus extrêmement rare
la plupart ont brûlé dans des réchaud de
fortune pour se chauffer pendant la
guerre
ces livres sont des rescapés comme vous
comme moi celui ci par exemple un
exemplaire des pensées de blaise pascal
blaise pascal mathématiciens physiciens
philosophe mystique inventeur de cette
petite machine à calculer en laiton la
pascaline considéré comme l'ancêtre de
tous les ordinateurs et c'est moins
connu entrepreneurs de transport public
avec le carrasso 5 sol cet homme était
une forêt à lui tout seul
nous l'avons pris comme modèle pour
notre école car si une école doit
produire des graines d'humanité si elle
doit former des hommes et des femmes
capables de reconstruire le monde s'il
venait à s'effondrer
alors aujourd'hui en 2050 une école doit
former des polymathe polymathe polymathe
poli plusieurs polymathe plusieurs
connaissances quelqu'un qui excellent
dans plusieurs domaines de connaissance
notre école de pot limit se trouve dans
un petit village loin des villes près
d'une ferme nous y accueillons des
enfants d'horizons divers souvent des
orphelins de guerre autant de filles que
de garçons tous portent le même pour
points voudra sont moins et si votre
enfant nous rejoint peut-être il ne
deviendra pas blaise pascal
il n'ya qu'un blaise pascal mais
assurément ici il développera une
puissance de concentration hors du
commun une mémoire extraordinaire et une
justesse de raisonnement que vous
pourriez trouver rapidement exaspérante
en tant que parent oui ici nous
développons le talent vous trouvez ça
peut être un peu exagéré de demander
autant à des enfants pourtant les
enfants sont capables de prodige
si on les leur demande et vous aussi
vous seriez en train de devenir des
pôles imad si comme eux vous aviez
rejoint une école où on se préoccupe de
ce talent mais comme moi vous êtes nés
avant la guerre avant la guerre le
talent était suspect on se méfie du
talent ont laissé en jachère et il
finissait toujours par s'étioler
avant la guerre l'omniprésence des
machines nous donner le droit d'être un
peu paresseux et d'en demander peu à ce
talent au nôtre et à celui des autres
avant la guerre les connaissances
n'était pas stockées sur des cerveaux
d'enfants elle n'était pas stockés dans
des livres elle était stockée dans un
réseau de réseaux un réseau tellement
robuste
que nous avons fini par lui confier
toutes les informations toutes les
communications les photos de famille
les conversations téléphoniques les
relevés bancaires les transactions
financières le fonctionnement des usines
et même celui des centrales électriques
quel beau chemin parcouru depuis la
pascaline
c'était la plus gigantesque bibliothèque
de connaissance jamais construite par
les hommes et nous y avions tous accès
sans restriction gratuitement à tout
moment et plus cette bibliothèque
grandissait et moi nous humains nous
avions l'envié et le besoin d'apprendre
et de se souvenir pourquoi se souvenir
au juste cette machine était éternelle à
en croire ses concepteurs elle ne devait
jamais faire défaut vanité des hommes
aurait dit blaise pascal
internet est tombé 1 mardi matin à 7h25
et avec lui tous les réseaux qui lui
étaient de près ou de loin connectés
pour une raison que nous ne connaîtrons
jamais je m'en souviens très bien
j'étais un petit garçon à l'époque je
prenais mon petit déjeuner je me
préparais à l'école ma mère était très
inquiète ce matin là elle avait allumé
la télévision
à la télévision on nous parlait d'une
escalade de violence entre deux
superpuissances dans la zone pacifique
soudain images sur la télévision c'est
gelé et très peu de temps après en poule
au plafond et télévision elle-même se
sont éteintes par tous était noir à
l'intérieur de l'appartement à
l'extérieur dans la rue ma mère s'est
jetée sur son téléphone portable pour
s'en servir comme d'une lampe torche
mais son téléphone ne fonctionnait plus
normalement et rapidement lui aussi
cet état connaissez la suite
tout est tombé en même temps les réseaux
les communications les monnaies la
confiance et personne n'était là pour
relancer cette machine les hommes des
villes dans leur colère ont tout saccagé
puis tout incendie les banques et les
banquiers les ministres dans leur
ministère et même les bibliothèques
lorsque nous avons fondé cette école
tous les professeurs se sont réunis et
nous nous sommes posé la question
essentielle qu'est ce qui fonde
véritablement un homme qu'est ce que
nous devons transmettre en priorité à
ces jeunes polymathe la volonté a dit le
professeur de philosophie il leur faudra
une volonté d'airain pour se soumettre à
tous ces apprentissages la mémoire a dit
le professeur d'histoire il leur faudra
une mémoire hors du commun dignes de
celles les érudits la renaissance
la raison a dit le professeur de
mathématiques en riant ce serait une
bonne chose qui ne se farcissent pas la
tête avec trop d'erreurs et de faussetés
quand même elles seraient imprimées dans
des livres volonté mémoire raison voilà
le socle de l'apprentissage de nos
jeunes polymathe volonté l'envié
d'apprendre et le capital le plus
précieux d'un enfant c'est aussi le plus
fragile ici chaque enfant est suivi par
un préfet des études
le préfet est là pour le rassurer
pour l'encourager mais aussi pour le
pousser dans ses retranchements pour
qu'ils continuent d'expérimenter
d'explorer tous les domaines dans
lesquels il pourrait avoir envie d'
excellent et on est souvent timides
enfin
son propre talent ce sont les préfets
qui leur enseignent aussi les techniques
de concentration que nous avons mise au
point de techniques de respiration très
simple pour qu'ils puissent se mettre au
travail sans effort et maintenir la
concentration constante pendant quelques
heures mais moi vous avez dû entendre
que certains nos élèves étaient capables
de réciter l'iliade d'homère et la
divine comédie de dante harker c'est
vrai et vous aussi vous en seriez
peut-être capables si comme vous aviez
été initiés aux arts de mémoire dans
notre école nous leur enseignons à
construire des palais de mémoire un
palais mémoire c'est un espace mental
dans lequel ils apprennent à ranger
leurs souvenirs et leur apprentissage
lorsqu'ils arrivent ici leur calais
n'est pas plus grand que leur chambre
quand ils nous quittent le palais est
devenu une architecture aussi vaste et
organisée qu'une cathédrale prête à
recevoir une très grande bibliothèque
raison chaque nouveau monde celle un
nouveau pacte avec la raison
la logique que nous enseignons à nos
élèves est triple le gic du langage
celle des hommes
logique mathématique celle de la nature
enfin logique informatique celle des
machines nous leur enseignons c3 logis
avec autant de profondeur mais je ne
parlerai que du langage et spa du
langage que dépend la paix future entre
les hommes ici nous leur enseignons à
détecter toute forme de mensonge
d'approximations et de trucages dans les
discours pour qu'ils se les interdisent
à eux mêmes les travaux pratiques
ce fonds à partir un trésor quelques
exemplaires de journaux imprimés avant
la guerre ce sont des mines des trésors
d'approximations et de trucages alors
volonté mémoire raison une fois que nous
avons posée ce socle est bien à l'enfant
peut enfin commencer à apprendre
apprendre quoi me demanderez vous
apprendre tout apprendre tout ce vers
quoi son talent le portera je vous
rassure ses enfants restent des enfants
ils font du sport il joue beaucoup au
ballon à la corde à sauter à 1000 jeux
que je serais bien en peine de vous
décrire mais si vous leur demandez ce
qu'il préfère dans notre école je crois
que beaucoup vous parlerez de nos
promenades en forêt la forêt la vraie
elle et au dehors tout proche
non sans la présence partout dans
l'école elle nous aide à faire
comprendre aux enfants quelque chose de
simple mais de très puissant le trésor
le plus précieux de notre école n'est
pas dans la bibliothèque
il n'est pas non plus dans les machines
que nous leur enseignons à construire et
à réparer non le trésor est là au dehors
dans cette forêt dans tout ce qui vit
alors le samedi matin nous emmenons les
enfants pour cette promenade pour leur
apprendre à regarder la forêt pousser la
règle c'est de ne jamais dire un seul
mot c'est une promenade silencieuse dans
cette forêt il voit toutes sortes de
plantes des arbres très variés voit
aussi des animaux des biches des
hérissons des renards un jour nous les
avions emmené pour observer quelques
jeunes fougères quand soudain un loup
est sorti des broussailles
j'ai envoyé un bras pour essayer les
protéger je regardais les enfants mais
aucun d'entre eux la bouche
aucun d'entre eux n'a dit un mot sont
restés silencieux regarder le loup et le
loup en réponse les a regardés il a
penché la tête comme pour les saluer et
puis il est parti à l'envoyer ces jeunes
polymathe c'est grain d'humanité seront
bientôt bâtir des villes entières
construire toutes les machines mais pour
rien au monde ils ne laisseraient
détruire un arpent de cette forêt même
pour en faire des livres chérissez la
connaissance merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]